on problem 129.
on a recent trip cindy drove her car 290
miles
290 miles rounded to the nearest 10
miles all right
and used 12 gallons of gasoline rounded
to the nearest gallon so 12
gallons
the actual number of miles per gallon
that cindy's car got on this trip must
have been between
okay so they they want us to kind of say
okay we round these are the rounded
numbers now what were the actual numbers
between and then from that what's the
range of miles per gallon so this is the
rounded to the nearest 10 then her miles
her miles had to have been
greater than
see greater than or equal to
285 right because anything 285 or more
would have been rounded to 290 but then
less than
right
because anything less than 295 would be
rounded down but 295 itself would be
rounded up to 300.
fair enough and her gallons her gallons
had to have been greater than or equal
to 11.5 gallons by the same logic and
less than
12.5 gallons
fair enough
so what was the lowest possible miles
per gallon so the lowest possible miles
per gallon would have the lowest miles
and the highest gallons right you want
to minimize the numerator and maximize
the denominator so lowest possible miles
the lowest possible miles would be
285 and the highest possible gallons
at least it'll approach 12.5
it'll approach 12.5
so this is you know
12.499999
is a possible number of gallons so it'll
approach this but it can never be
exactly 12.5 gallons so her miles per
gallon are going to be greater than this
it would have been greater than equal to
this was like 12.4999999
but since 12.5 we can never get there
we're going to be greater than this in
terms of miles per gallon
and then the highest possible miles per
gallon is the highest possible miles
which is 295 but we're never going to be
able to go twice quite there
right we're always going to be less than
and then the lowest number of gallons
right using going the highest mileage
with the lowest possible gallons you
want to minimize the denominator divided
by 11.5
let's see if that is a choice
so they say
let's see i don't see that exactly but
it choice d looks interesting because
choice d says so they say the actual
number of miles per gallon that cindy's
car got on this trip must have been
between
choice
d looks
close
looks close to what we have right
because we have this choice d says
between
divided by 12.5 so 284 divided by 12.5
that's going to be even less than that
right
because you have the 12.5 but the
numerator is less so that's going to be
even lower than the range that we have
and then on choice d
295 divided by 11.4 295 divided by 11.4
this is this number is larger than this
number because you have the same
numerator and you have a smaller
denominator so you're dividing by a
smaller number so this number is larger
so if my if her miles per gallon is
between these two numbers and these two
numbers are between these two numbers
then yeah d is right her miles per
gallon need to be before between 284
divided by 12.5 and 295 divided by 11.4
so it's choice d
problem 130
which of the following inequalities is
an algebraic expression for the shaded
part of the number line above
okay so this number line
let's try to draw it that's the line
and i'm going to draw all of the dots on
it but it essentially starts at positive
and it goes backwards
switch colors it goes positive 3. well
not all no it starts at it's essentially
from minus five to positive three
that's all of what this includes
this includes
minus five to positive 3 then you have
you know 2 1
0 and then minus 5. so you could say
that
x is
less than or equal to 3 because it's
filled in at 3 and greater than or equal
to -5
and that's not one of the choices they
want in terms of absolute value
right so they want the absolute value so
what we can view this is this is a range
around some number whenever you're
dealing with absolute value you're
essentially saying the distance from
some number so this is a range let's see
minus 5 and three this has a length of
eight
so they're both four away from minus one
right
think about it you could go four
backwards
or four four words right
so one way to think about it is the
difference between x the difference
between x and minus one
x and minus one
the difference between x and minus one
and that might be a negative or positive
difference depending on whether we're
positive or negative but we just want
the absolute
we the depending on whether we're above
negative one or below negative one we
just want the absolute difference right
we just want the distance away from
negative one
so the distance away from negative one
and that's given by this right the
difference between any x
and negative one
and we took the absolute value in case x
is less than negative one the distance
is going to be less than or equal to
four right
because
uh if we go above negative one we're at
most at three which is four more than
negative one
and if we go below negative one we're at
minus five which is four less than
negative one so it's less than or equal
to four
so if you simplify this you get x plus
one the absolute value is less than or
equal to four
and that is choice e
and this is a useful skill to i don't
know you're probably taking the sct
already but in general a lot of
standardized tests think of absolute
value as a distance in one dimension
right so distance along the number line
so you're saying oh well all of these
points there's some
there's some within some range from one
point and you could say oh if you take
the midpoint of this you're negative one
and every point here is within four of
negative one so the distance between
every point on this line every x that
satisfies this and negative one the
distance is less than or equal to 4.
anyway i kind of just did the problem
twice for you
problem 131
a factory has 500 workers
500 workers 15 percent of whom are women
so 15
times 500
is equal to women
if 50 additional workers are to be hired
and all of the present workers remain
how many of the additional workers must
be women
in order to raise the percent of women
employees to 20 percent
okay so how many women workers do we
have right now five times 15 we have 75
workers right
15 times 500
yep yeah five times yep 75
right we have 75 women right now
so right now
we 75
if we wanted to find the proportion of
women it's 75 over 500 which is once
again it's 15.
it's 15 percent and let's see we're
going to add a total of 50 workers to
this population
and they want to know
how many of the additional workers must
be women in order to raise the percent
of women in population 20
so writing 50 total workers and then so
how many of those have to be women in
order for the new proportion right this
is going to be the new number of women
the number of women that are added to
the 75 that are already there divided by
the 500 workers who are there plus the
50 new some of whom who might be women
so this is now this now has to equal 20
percent
so let's see we get 75 plus w that's a w
over 550
is equal to 0.2
what so we get 75
plus
the number of women that need to be
added is equal to
see
0.2 times 550
we multiply both sides times 550 that
equals 110
right yep 110
110 right
110 and then so subtract 75 from both
sides women it has to be equal to 110
minus 75
and that's equal to
see 25 plus 10 that's equal to 35.
35 of the 50 women 35 of the 50
employees have to be women and that's
what they ask right how many of the
additional workers must be women so
that's choice e
next question 132
132 in a small snack shop the average
arithmetic mean revenue was 400 dollars
per day over a 10 10-day period so the
average over 10 days was 400
during this period if the average daily
revenue was 360 for the first six days
so the average of six days was 360. what
was the average daily revenue for the
last four days
so we've done a lot of problems like
this hopefully this is a bit of second
nature if you've watched the solution to
the other ones but what's the the
average of all of them well it's the
average of the first six days right so
the average of the first six days we
could almost assume that the first six
days had exactly 360 in revenue
so it's their average times six so this
would be the total revenue of the first
six days
plus
what's the total revenue of the next
four days what's going to be the average
of the next four days
times four right that would be the total
of those four we're not saying that they
all have to be exactly the average but
when you sum them all up they're equal
to the average divided the average times
four
now if you divide all of those this is
the total of the revenue of all 10 days
if you take that sum and divided by 10
you get the average for the 10 days
and that is equal to 400.
let's simplify this a little bit
let's see what we could do well we get
let's see if we could so we get 3
times 6 plus
a let's just say 8 well i'll call it the
average for 4 days times 4
is equal to 10 times 400 which is 4 000.
let's see we can immediately we could
before i get in too involved in
multiplication let's divide both sides
of this equation by 4.
so 360 divided by 4 that's 90 times 6
plus this divided by four plus a four is
equal to
one thousand
ninety times six
is five hundred forty
plus the average of the four days is
equal to one thousand
so the average of the four days is equal
to one thousand
minus five hundred forty
which is what that's four hundred and
sixty dollars is equal to four hundred
sixty dollars per day and that's choice
d
and i'm out of time see in the next
video